This decision to make parts of the pipeline programmable is in fact one of the
challenges of computer chip design. The designers have to decide how many
transistors are dedicated to memory cache and registers, how many to
instruction processing, and how many to dedicated algorithm logic. CPUs spend
their transistors on memory caches and instruction processing. GPUs use to
spend theirs almost entirely on algorithm logic. Which is also called
fixed-function processing. What's great about the fixed-function logic is that
it can be extremely fast while using less transistors and less power. The
drawback of fixed-function logic is that you're locked in. The trend over the
past decade or so has been to add to the GPU more and more instruction
processing, in other words, more general programmability. In our pipeline the
vertex and fragment shaders are programmable. Only those tests that are
commonly performed and have large bang for the buck have survived as fixed
function hardware in the pipeline. For example, triangle set up and
rasterization as well as z depth testing are used all the time and do not
normally need programmability.